hi my name is Neerja Agarwal I'm a
graduate student here at MIT in the
physical optics and electronics lab our
lab is trying to do non-invasive
Diagnostics using spectroscopy Raman
spectroscopy is a technique in which you
shine laser light at a sample and
measure the scattered photons now this
gives you a spectral fingerprint of the
molecule clinical trials I've already
shown this to be an effective technique
for cancer diagnostics but we need a way
to develop and test new instruments in
the laboratory setting before jumping to
expensive clinical trials during my
Master's research I showed that you can
use an in vitro skin tissue culture as
an optical substitute for human skin
instead of jumping to clinical trials I
showed that the skin tissue culture has
similar Raman autofluorescence
and optical properties as human skin
with more than 25 volunteers as
comparison making it an invaluable R&D
tool now another challenge with this
technique is that you're measuring are
really small Raman signal on top of a
large autofluorescence background I
looked at ways to separate these two
signals in time using time correlated
single photon counting thereby improving
the signal-to-noise ratio now Raman
spectroscopy is already undergoing
commercialization and these two results
will accelerate the product development
process bringing it closer to patients